Êtes-vous prêts à voir une nouvelle image de moi que vous ne pourrez jamais oublier ?
On va regarder ensemble mes toutes premières vidéos.
Alors, je vous vois venir. Oui, il y a d'autres YouTubeurs qui ont déjà fait ça.
J'ai vu un petit peu d'autres gars montrer effectivement leurs premières vidéos, genre :
"Oh regardez c'était y'a deux ans, euh, holala"
Attendez, regardez de quoi je parle là.
Voici ma première vidéo que j'ai postée sur Internet.
Il y a 12 ans.
Y'a des jeunes qui regardent cette vidéo actuellement,
qui sont plus jeunes que cette vidéo.
Vous voyez un petit peu le délire ?
En faisant cette vidéo, je le reconnais, j'ai l'impression d'être le
Le Michel Drucker de YouTube.
J'ai commencé il y a très, très longtemps.
Déjà, c'était sur Dailymotion.
Ça se trouve y'a des gens qui ne savent même pas ce que c'est.
C'est le Minitel de YouTube.
C'est le YouTube créé par des Français, qui n'a jamais marché.
Du coup c'était il y a 12 ans.
Je découvre Dailymotion, YouTube, on peut poster des vidéos.
Je vois le caméscope de mes parents, je vois un câble, je vois mon ordinateur.
Je dis : "Y'a moyen de faire quelque chose."
Qu'est-ce que je fais en premier ?
De l'humour ? Non.
Un court-métrage ! Non.
De l'animation ? Pas du tout !
Ma première vidéo est une vidéo...
De GAMING !
Je suis un joueur dans l'âme !
Et c'était tellement roots à l'époque, que je filmais ma Nintendo DS pour vous présenter un jeu japonais.
C'est ma toute première vidéo, je n'ai pas envie de vous montrer ça, mais c'est pas grave on y va quand même.
"Salut salut ! Alors, j'ai envie de te poser une question c'est : qu'est-ce que Ōendan ?"
"Bon, j'espère que ça va marcher parce que ma..."
J'espère qu'ça va marcher.
"Alors, Ōendan, tu sais pas ce que c'est, bah ça tombe bien..."
Voilà... En fait, j'ai fait cette vidéo dans l'unique but,
de montrer que j'avais un logiciel pirate sur ma Nintendo DS là, qu'j'suis en train de montrer.
Et de dire : voilà, j'peux télécharger des jeux japonais, etc...
C'était ma manière de me la raconter un petit peu.
C'est un jeu de musique qui est excellent au passage.
Tout ce que je vais faire c'est jouer à un put*** de jeu.
Et je me rappelle très bien de la fin de cette vidéo.
"Elle descend dangereusement... Ah ben y'a plus de piles !"
"Donc voila ça tombe bien, je voulais vous parler de Ōendan, c'est un jeu sur DS..."
Ma console s'est éteinte !
Je fais une vidéo avec une console déchargée !
À quoi ça sert ?
On voit un bout du trépied là, avec le caméscope de mes parents.
Très souvent on me demande "Cyprien est-ce que tu pensais devenir Youtubeur etc, quand tu t'es lancé ?"
MAIS BIEN SÛR QUE NON !
Ma console s'éteint pendant que je joue et je le met en ligne !
Je n'imaginais pas en faire mon métier un jour, je n'avais aucune rigueur pour ça !
Est-ce qu'y a encore des commentaires sur... Ah nan y'a plus de commentaire sur Dailymotion !
Dailymotion a supprimé les commentaires... Je pense que si ça ne marche pas.. Dailymotion c'est aussi un petit peu à cause d'eux !
Mes miniatures de vidéos, en dessous, on peut les voir.
Elles ont toutes été supprimées ! Ouais, Dils ont supprimé les miniatures.
Ils se disent : comme ça les gens ils cliquent, ils ne savent pas ce que c'est...
Quelle est ma deuxième vidéo que je poste sur Internet ?
De la fiction ? Non.
Un sketch ?! Non.
Bah, du gaming ? Non !
Ma deuxième vidéo s'appelle "Poum Tchac Bapbeuloulap" : pire titre ever.
Voici le garage de mes parents, dans le sud de la France. Je suis assis dans le fond là.
Qualité... c'est du 4k ça !
Et un peu à la manière du test du jeu vidéo là...
C'est que c'est du tourné-monté, c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de cut !
"Là, ça filme ?"
" Quand c'est rouge comme ça, ouais, c'est bon, ouais ouais !"
On entend le guitariste dire "Là ça filme ?" au début.
"Là, ça filme ?" "Quand c'est rouge comme ça, ouais, c'est bon, ouais ouais"
Là ça filme quand c'est rouge comme ça ? Oui, tout à fait !
Je me rappelle c’était au lycée et on avait un mur pour poster un peu des annonces et tout..
" Je cherche un guitariste", "cherche un batteur" etc...
Et Alex, que j'ai peut-être croisé trois fois dans ma vie.
On avait décidé d'essayer de faire, voilà guitare/gratte ensemble.
Moi je faisais de la batterie, lui faisait de la guitare.
Et ! Ca a été imortalisé. Alex', big-up à toi !
*Musique*
Put***, j’accélère de ouf'... Bah oui, je fais de la batterie !
Quels sont les rêves à l'époque ? C'est de jouer à des jeux vidéos toute ta vie,
Ou être star du rock !
Je suis en short avec des vieilles Asics flinguées là.
Avec un mec, que j'ai rencontré, y'a deux heures.
Une musique qu'on a jamais répétée ensemble.
C'était pas du tout préparé.
C'était il y a douze ans.
Je ne savais pas que j'allais filmer beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup d'autres choses.
Et ben ça passe par ça.
Ça passe par... essayer de bricoler un petit peu à gauche à droite...
Pourquoi pas du gaming, pourquoi pas de la musique...
À l'époque, tout me semblait possible.
Bref.
Ce n'est pas terminé sur mes toutes premières vidéos !
Loin de là...
Ma première vidéo : on ne me voit pas.
Deuxième vidéo : je suis en petit, grand comme ça dans des pixels, au fond du garage.
Je vais enfin, sur ma troisième vidéo, montrer le potentiel, de mon physique... avantageux !
Je me filme, dans ma chambre. Vous allez découvrir ma chambre, de l'époque.
Et je crois, que vous ne me verrez plus jamais de la même manière...
Ça va piquer les yeux. Attention, âmes sensibles s'abstenir !
*À voix basse* "Euh... Bonjour bonsoir, euh... Euh... C'est Monsieur Dream. Euh... Aujourd'hui je vais vous faire part d'un de mes coups de gueule."
*Soupire*
Par où commencer ?
C'est la première fois que je me filme réellement.
Je suis l'homme le plus coincé... DE LA PLANÈTE !
*À voix basse* Oui bonjour, c'est Monsieur Dream.
Ça, c'était mon pseudo. Pire pseudo !
*À voix basse* Bonjour, c'est moi, c'est Monsieur Dream. Aujourd’hui j'aimerais vous parler d'un truc.
ENLÈVE CE BALAI DE TON CUL !
Il y avait mes parents, qui n'étaient pas loin. Dans la chambre d'à côté, dans le couloir...
Et du coup je voulais faire ça en scred...
Du genre : si personne ne pouvait passer à côté de ma porte et m'entendre,
pour que je sois le moins humilié possible, ça m'arrangerait.
J'ai la lampe de mon bureau dans la gueule, rien ne va.
Et derrière, on découvre un petit peu ma petite chambre d'ado.
Avec des posters, avec des meufs à moitié à poil.
Les mangas, les meufs à moitié à poil : c'était mon obsession à l’époque !
Et la thématique de cette vidéo... En fait je faisais du dessin sur tablette graphique,
et en fait, le stylet ne marchait plus. J'ai dû en racheter un, ça coutait genre presque 100€, j'étais dégouté...
Et du coup je me suis dit "Tiens ! C'est exactement un sujet qui intéresse les gens !"
*À voix basse* "T'imagines le médecin... Sympa..."
Put*** mais ! Encore une vidéo sans montage. On me voit à la fin, en train d'éteindre la caméra !
Nouvelle vidéo ! Là c'est bon, j'étais piqué, il fallait que fasse des vidéos très régulièrement.
Même si c'était flingué comme ça, si je chuchotais...
Mais j'étais tellement content de pouvoir poster ça sur Internet, et de me dire :
" Qu'est ce que je vais pouvoir faire après ?"
" Rebonjour, c'est pas moi. Le mot du jour est :
Wouah ! Quel montage professionnel !
"Sentiment mêlé de tristesse et de déception"
Déjà, fallait que je vous le dise, j'ai monté avec Windows Movie Maker,
qui est le logiciel de montage pour les enfants, pour les fœtus. Le truc que tu as gratuitement sur ton ordinateur Windows.
D'où les effets incroyables : le mot qui arrive "Amertume", qui bam', tu vois.
Je racontais un truc de merde, genre je voulais rencontrer quelqu'un, mais j'ai pas pu le rencontrer, bref.
C'est un truc absolument pas du tout passionnant !
Mais, j'aimerais vous reparler encore à nouveau de la décoration de ma piaule, pour montrer que j'étais un peu...
Un ado. Un vrai ado !
À droite, encore une meuf', manga, dans son lit, mes couilles là.
Et à gauche, j'avais un poster : The Simple Life.
Ça, c'est The Simple Life.
C'est une télé-réalité, avec Paris Hilton et... une autre meuf, bref.
Qui sont deux américaines, pétées de thunes, et qui décident de voyager.
Et je me suis dit "Put***, deux meufs' à moitié à poil, bien, je vais mettre ça dans ma chambre."
Je n'ai jamais vu cette émission !
Je viens d'apprendre il n'y a pas longtemps, quel était le concept de l'émission :
C'est des meufs, elles vont à la ferme. Hey', c'est pour ça qu'elle a une fourche et tout.
Hey' mais j'étais trop con !
Mes hormones faisaient effets !
J'assumais pas trop mes lunettes, je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Et, déjà à l'époque, à 17/18 ans, j'avais déjà de la...
De la barbe. Et là encore, je me rasais de temps en temps
Mais... Ce que je ne savais pas, c'est que ça allait pousser un peu partout. Bref !
Je commençais à faire de plus en plus de vidéos.
200 vues, 300 vues... Toujours filmées dans ma piaule, à l'arrache etc.
Je me suis dit "Tiens, je deviens professionnel !"
Avec le caméscope de mes parents, qu'est ce qu'il me faudrait ?
Un générique !
Un générique.
Je n'ai pas de logiciel de 3D. Je ne sais pas faire de graphismes.
Je n'ai rien d'autre, si ce n'est mon caméscope.
Je vais vous montrer, quelle a été l'introduction de mes vidéos, pendant peut-être deux ans !
♪ Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta Ta ♪
♪ Monsieur Dream ♪
*bruitages*
"Miam"
Maître de l'animation, c'est moi ! Hayao Miyazaki, il se chie dessus !
Il est comme ça, il fait "Mon dieu ! Quel talent !"
Je voulais créer un générique. J'ai filmé une ardoise, qui est... à l'envers !
Il y a le logo !
Et j'ai juste dessiné des trucs et j'avais vraiment le budget de la Roumanie !
Et j'étais fier de ça !
Je mettais ce générique de merde à chaque fois devant mes vidéos, c'est incroyable.
Je n'ai plus jamais fait d'animation après ça.
Cette vidéo, "Monsieur Dream dans la presse", je rappelle, Monsieur Dream, c'est mon pseudo.
Je me cachais derrière une identité secrète !
Là, j'étais à Aix-en-Provence. Je venais d'arriver à la fac ! Donc je pense que je devais avoir tout juste dix-huit ans.
Et, je suis passé dans la presse. J'étais fier !
" Voilà, c'est ma nouvelle caméra...Donc..."
Mon camescope !
Wow !
Les gros plans...
Là je commence, je commence à me ressembler plus je trouve.
Je commence à me ressembler !
" Tadaaam' ! Et oui, je suis passé, dans le dernier FHM !"
"Donc ça se passe ici, ici, mais surtout, ici."
Blague in-cro-yable...
Je montre "Le Monde", alors qu'en fait, c'était derrière, c'était dans le magazine FHM.
Pour ceux qui ne savent pas, c'est un magazine avec, heu... des sujets en tout genre...Mais surtout des meufs' à moitié à poil.
Je le rappelle, j'étais un pervers sexuel à l'époque !
Mais toujours dans la légalité, n'est-ce-pas.
Et, ça parlait, en fait, de l'iPhone. L'iPhone venait d'arriver.
Et ça, c'est très drôle, parce qu'en fait, j'avais fait à l'époque, mon premier "buzz".
C'était une vidéo où je parle de l'iPhone. L'iPhone venait d'être annoncé.
Je le sais, il y a des enfants qui regardent, pour eux l'iPhone ça a toujours existé.
Mais non ! C'est un peu mon Minitel à moi. Ok ?
J'avais fait une vidéo dessus. Il faut que je vous montre ça.
"L'iPhone ! Donc j'ai completement craqué pour ce produit, car, c'est le téléphone portable le plus complet qui existe."
Blague incroyable !
J'avais imprimé une photo de l'iPhone, puisqu'il venait juste d'être annoncé.
Et je l'avais collée sur des Duplos.
"Avant de commencer les détails techniques, j'aimerais quand même souligner sa très petite taille, et son extrême..."
Hey' !
Logo Apple ! Y'avait un truc qui avait un oeil, donc j'avais fait comme si c'était le logo...
Oh... Tuez-moi put***...
Woah ! Mise-en-scène incroyable en fait...
Je portais ce genre de chemises à l'époque.
"J'ai rêvé que je claquais 600€ dans un objet pourri !"
Mais mon petit Cyprien, si tu savais ce que tu allais mettre dans un smartphone mon pote !
Et en fait, je passe ma vidéo à le démonter.
Je dis "Mais c'est n'importe quoi, y'avait pas la 3G dessus..."
Je suis si peu visionnaire, c'est incroyable !
Je regarde l'iPhone, et je fais "Non, ça marchera jamais..."
223 000 vues. En vues Dailymotion, c'est l'équivalent de Gangnam Style !
Je ne sais pas prononcer Gangnam Style.
C'était un buzz MONUMENTAL !
Là, je commence à avoir un peu ma routine etc.
J’essaie de m'éclater un petit peu, vous voyez. Des montages, des trucs, y'a des cuts !
Ce qu'il n'y avait pas du tout au début.
Toujours j’essaie de trouver des trucs un petit peu créatifs. Comment m'amuser...
Par exemple, là, j'avais fabriqué un "Paper-Toy" : une petite figurine en papier, que les gens peuvent faire.
Et que j'avais customisé avec une gueule qui ne me ressemble PAS DU TOUT !
Je vous montre à quoi cela ressemble à la fin.
J'adorais faire ce genre de trucs un petit peu improbables, avec du papier, des trucs...J'avais déjà fait des tee-shirts !
J'avais vendu sur Ebay, y'avait genre cinq pièces.
J'avais fait des stickers aussi ! Des stickers où les gens m'envoyaient une enveloppe pré-timbrée à leurs noms.
Et moi je mettais les stickers dedans et l'enveloppe repartait.
Mais en tous cas, ça m'éclatait de faire des dessins, de créer des choses et d'avoir une interaction avec la communauté.
Si aujourd'hui je ferais pareil, je recevrais je pense un peu trop d'enveloppes, pour un seul homme.
Mais, ce n'est pas la seule chose un petit peu folichonne, fifolle.
Voilà... je faisais des bruits un peu chelous. Ok... ce bruit là.
"Ah oui, il faut ça aussi : Hey', hey' !"
Je chante, et... voilà le résultat :
*Bruitages*
♪ Okay ! Hein Hein ! C'est moi Cyprien ! Hein Hein ! ♪
♪ Je rentre dans la place, je suis le numéro 1 ! Pour combien de temps ? Ca on ne le sait pas ! Cyprien First s'il vous plaît ! ♪
Voilà ce genre de trucs qui n'ont aucun sens, qui ont fait quand même 22000 vues.
Le CV vidéo de Monsieur Dream...
Ah oui... Ce qui était à la mode, c'était de faire des CV vidéos pour essayer de trouver un boulot.
Et... J'avais parodié ça.
Voilà, je disais "Ouais, moi je suis super", je suis devant la tour Eiffel etc.
"... réaliser mon CV vidéo !"
Ouais...
Est-ce qu'il y avait des blagues dedans ?
"J'aime la nature"
Holala...
Okay, d'accord... Vous voyez le genre, "j'aime la nature", je fais un bisous à un arbre, je suis sur les chiottes...
"Je fais aussi de la vidéo sur Internet. J'ai déjà réalisé plusieurs courts-métrages"
L'humour, ça se travaille !
C'est le genre de vidéos que je faisais il y a dix ans.
Je commençais petit à petit à faire de plus en plus de vidéos face-caméra.
Même si... c'est des vidéos de merde. Mais c'est des vidéos, que j'affectionne particulièrement.
Dix ans, c'est énorme quand même. On se rend pas compte du temps qui passe, c'est OUF' !
On va terminer avec un dernier petit truc.
*Bruitages électroniques*
C'était un site pour pouvoir faire des bruits avec son clavier.
J'avais tourné ce truc là chez mon ancien employeur, à 20minutes.fr.
ÇA EXISTE ENCORE !
Génial, on va se terminer là-dessus.
*Bruitages électroniques*
Merci d'avoir regardé cette petite review des vidéos qui te mettent mal à l'aise,
parce que tu es jeune et inexpérimenté, bien évidemment !
Désolé pour tout le malaise que je vous ai procuré.
Mais pour moi, je suis et dégouté, et attendri par moi-même. C'est marrant, hein ?
C'est un sentiment très étrange, il faudrait trouver un mot français pour ça.
On se dit à très vite ! C'était une petite vidéo, comme ça, en mode chill.
Parce que, je suis en train de travailler sur mon prochain court-métrage,
que je tourne bientôt, au Japon, dans quelques semaines.
Et donc voilà, je voulais déjà interagir un petit peu avec vous, avec des petits souvenirs malaisants.
Moi, je vous dis à très vite. N'hésitez pas à vous abonner !
*Musique*